every week this mystery box shows up at
my doorstep it's one of those
subscription boxes except instead of dog
toys or makeup it's food from local
farmers and I never know exactly what
I'm gonna get I've got some salad greens
asparagus and red corn that's weird but
this wasn't always such an unusual sight
if you look through old seed catalogs
like these ones you'll see hundreds of
varieties of corn with names like
dibbles mammoth Kendall's early giant
and my personal favorite putters
excelsior but none of these varieties
exist anymore American farmers used to
grow hundreds of varieties of sweet corn
tomatoes and other edible plants today
just a tiny fraction of those varieties
are still around so what happened to all
these plants for most of our time on
this planet humans have been
hunter-gatherers we ate what was nearby
this was still true when we invented
farming ten thousand years ago by
cultivating wild plants like teosinte in
Central America in Thornapple in Africa
the Middle East in Southeast Asia
over thousands of years farmers bred
these wild ancestors into foods like
corn and eggplant that we would
recognize today as humans moved around
the world so did the seeds and farmers
continue to breed different varieties to
adapt them to their new environments
which led to a ton of genetic diversity
farmers could raise different genetic
varieties of different crops
if disease or pest killed one type there
were others to fall back on but
gradually industrialization and cheap
fossil fuels made us less dependent on
what grew well nearby most farmers
switched from growing a variety of
edible plants to a single crop that was
easy to process and shipped as this
model spread beyond the United States
older varieties of plants and animals
disappeared from farms around the world
by 1970 90% of the wheat varieties that
had once been grown in China were gone
as were 80% of their varieties of maize
or corn that were once grown in Mexico
by the summer of 1971 more than 85% of
the corn planted in the US was
genetically identical crop scientists
had bred this new corn so that it grew
without a tassel making it easier to
harvest but because these plants were
genetic copies of one another that also
made them susceptible to the same deadly
fungus southern leaf corn blight it took
over the US corn crop costing farmers
and taxpayers millions of dollars and
the damage would have continued if it
weren't for a humble little plant cook
teosinte the wild grass native to Oaxaca
Mexico and the common ancestor of the
22,000 known varieties of corn to sente
includes a gene for resistance to the
same fungus that was devastating the US
corn crop scientists halted the damage
by crossbreeding teosinte with American
corn but that didn't totally solve the
problem of genetic diversity today more
than 40% of the corn grown in the u.s.
is derived from just six inbred lines
and seed companies driven by profit will
often repackage genetic copies of the
same seeds for different prices farmers
plant them thinking that they're
genetically diversifying their fields
when really they're not since the corn
crisis in 1971 disease has ravaged
genetically uniform crops of beans rice
tomatoes and bananas and it's about to
get worse the plants we eat have spent
thousands of years evolving to grow in
specific conditions conditions we're
changing rapidly by releasing more and
more carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
we depend on corn wheat and rice for
more than 60% of our global calories and
by 2050 we'll have 2 billion more people
to feed but because of climate change
we'll actually be producing less of all
3 of these crops we're going to need
plants that can grow in radically
different conditions and the more
genetic varieties we save the better
protected will be there are seed banks
all over the world where scientists
indigenous communities and farmers are
all preserving older seed varieties but
thousands have already been lost which
is why it's so critical to preserve the
genetic diversity we still
have weird stuff like red popcorn and
the best way to save the seeds that
might save us one day is to grow them
and eat them
you